Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. G'day and welcome to The Rest Is History. So we are now into our great World Cup saga and we are turning to perhaps not one of the obvious football nations, but these days a perennial qualifier, and that is the great country of Australia. And Tom, I believe for the Australian theme today,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。现在我们进入了伟大的世界杯系列节目，我们要关注的可能不是哪个耳熟能详的足球强国，但如今它是一个世界杯常客，那就是伟大的澳大利亚。汤姆，我听说关于今天的澳大利亚主题，
you've chosen the life and career of Ian Botham. Is that correct? Very good, yes. Of course, Australia's real sport is cricket, not football. No, Dominic, I have not chosen the life and career of Ian Botham. I have chosen the mystery of the Somerton Man, which is Australia's top mystery. Top mystery.
你选择了伊恩·博瑟姆（Ian Botham）的生平与职业生涯。是这样吗？非常好，是的。当然，澳大利亚真正的运动板球，而不是足球。不，多米尼克，我没有选择伊恩·博瑟姆的生平与职业生涯。我选择了萨顿镇神秘男子案（The Mystery of the Somerton Man），这是澳大利亚排名第一的谜团。顶级谜团。
And I learned about it when I went to the beautiful city of Adelaide, known as the city of churches, probably Australia's mellowest city. But also I learned when I was there at this literary festival, because I had a whole day of talks devoted to it, it has the most extraordinary array of murders that have been perpetrated in Adelaide. So it's a city of churches and it's a city of murders. And the thing that struck me about these murders is that basically a kind of terrible or fascinating or intriguing murder comes along pretty much once every decade. And they seem to correspond to the kind of the trends in detective fiction so yeah so um in the 90s when thomas harris was you know busy with hannibal lector and science the lambs and all that kind of stuff um you have the snow town murders and snow town was a place in all i think north of Adelaide. But they're also known as the Bodies in the Barrels murder.
我是当我去了阿德莱德这座美丽的城市时了解到它的，阿德莱德被称为教堂之城，大概是澳大利亚最温和的城市。但我在那里的文学节上还了解到——因为我有一整天的演讲都是关于这个的——这座城市发生过极其离奇的谋杀案。所以这是一座教堂之城，也是一座谋杀之城。这些谋杀案让我震惊的是，基本上每隔大约十年，就会发生一起可怕、迷人或引人入胜的谋杀案。而且它们似乎与侦探小说的某种潮流相吻合。所以，嗯……在90年代，当托马斯·哈里斯（Thomas Harris）正忙着写《沉默的羔羊》（Hannibal Lecter and Science the Lambs）之类的小说时，嗯，发生了雪镇谋杀案（Snowtown Murders），雪镇是阿德莱德以北的一个地方。但它们也被称为“木桶藏尸案”。
Barrels, plural. Barrels, plural, because these are the remains of eight victims that were found in plastic barrels in an abandoned bank vault. Very grisly. Yes, a very horrible story. Very, very Thomas Harris. very very thomas harris um and then in the 70s there were the truro murders where there were uh seven women who were murdered by two very unpleasant men but and the whole story again when you read it has a kind of real quality of one of those dark kind of dirty harry type films i mean right kind of noir cops on the edge all that kind of stuff uh But the most intriguing of the Adelaide murder stories is the one that you get
木桶，复数。木桶，复数，因为这些是在一个废弃银行金库的塑料桶里发现的八名受害者的遗骸。非常阴森。是的，一个非常可怕的故事。非常、非常托马斯·哈里斯风格。非常、非常托马斯·哈里斯式的。然后，在70年代，发生了特鲁罗谋杀案（Truro murders），有七名女性被两个非常讨厌的男人谋杀。但整个故事当你读起来时，同样具有那种真正的黑色电影或《肮脏的哈里》式电影的特质——我的意思是，那种正邪边缘的硬汉警察，诸如此类的一切。但阿德莱德谋杀案中最引人入胜的故事，是你在
in the 40s. And this is The Mystery of the Somerton Man, which would be a title that you might get, say, from Naya Marsh or Marjorie Allingham, or I guess Dorothea O'Sears, or even Agatha Christie. I mean, it's that golden age, the queens of crime. And this is the most extraordinary story. And when I heard about it, I kind of became mildly obsessed by it. And I think quite a lot of people who stumble across this story do become obsessed. And in fact, towards the end of this episode, we'll come to someone who became really obsessed. So the Somerton Man is named after Somerton Park Beach, which is about seven miles outside the centre of Adelaide. So Adelaide is, for those people who don't know, Adelaide is whereabouts in Australia?
40年代看到的这个。这就是萨顿镇神秘男子案，这个标题你可能会在内约·马什（Nyo Marsh）、马乔里·阿林汉姆（Marjorie Allingham），或者我想多萝西·L·塞耶斯（Dorothea O'Sayers），甚至阿加莎·克里斯蒂（Agatha Christie）的书里看到。我的意思是，那是黄金时代，是犯罪女王们的时代。这是一个极其离奇的故事。当我听说它时，我有点对它着迷了。我想很多偶然发现这个故事的人都会着迷。事实上，在本集接近尾声时，我们会提到一个真正着迷的人。所以，萨顿镇男子是以萨顿镇公园海滩（Somerton Park Beach）命名的，该海滩距离阿德莱德市中心大约七英里。对于那些不知道的人来说，阿德莱德是澳大利亚的哪个地方？
It's South Australia. Right. South Australia. And it's the one of the biggest, it's the fifth biggest city in Australia? Third, I think. I think it's the third largest, I think, after Sydney and Melbourne, I think. Okay. May have got that wrong.
它是南澳大利亚州。对。南澳大利亚州。它是最大的城市之一，是澳大利亚第五大城市吗？第三大，我想。我认为它是仅次于悉尼和墨尔本的第三大城市，我想。好吧。我可能搞错了。
But not directly relevant to the drama and intrigue of the story. Let's not get bogged down in the size of cities. I mean, we're not a geography podcast. What are its major industries? What's the name of its river? If we were a geography podcast, I think we'd have been taken off more than a year ago. I mean, we can provide that as kind of maybe supplementary information perhaps later. But I don't have those facts to hand at the moment.
但这与故事的戏剧性和悬疑感没有直接关系。我们不要纠结于城市的大小。我的意思是，我们不是一个地理播客。它的主要产业是什么？它的河流叫什么名字？如果我们是一个地理播客，我想我们在一年多前就被停播了。我的意思是，我们或许可以在以后提供这些作为补充信息。但我手头现在没有这些事实。
Okay. So the story begins on the 30th of November, 1948. And of course, that is, you know, it's the beginning of the Australian summer because they do things all the way around there. And in the evening, it's not a busy beach. It's not Bondi Beach. But, you know, there's not a busy beach. It's not Bondi Beach. But, you know, there's the odd person strolling out. And somebody sees this man who is lying on his back with his head propped up against the seawall on the beach. And the man lifts his arm, waves, and then puts it back down again.
好吧。所以故事始于1948年11月30日。当然，那是澳大利亚夏天的开始，因为南半球的季节是反过来的。在傍晚时分，这不是一个繁忙的海滩。它不是邦迪海滩（Bondi Beach）。但是，你知道，这不是一个繁忙的海滩。它不是邦迪海滩。但是，你知道，会有零星的人在散步。有人看到这个男人仰面躺着，头部靠在海滩的防波堤上。那人抬起手臂，挥了挥，然后又放了下来。
So he's clearly fine. Another group of people look down and they see him there and he moves but they do know something which is odd which is that he's surrounded by mosquitoes but he's not swatting them away so that they know that and they think yeah he's moving he's moving so they think nothing more of it the beach empties night comes down dawn first of december and there are two jockeys who are practicing riding up and down on the beach and they see this bloke lying there and they wave to him no no response they gallop up the beach and they come back and he still hasn't moved and so they get off their horses and they
所以他显然没事。另一群人往下看，看到他躺在那里，他动了。但他们注意到了一件奇怪的事，那就是他周围有蚊子，但他却没有把它们拍开。所以他们知道这一点，他们心想，是的，他在动，他在动，所以他们没把这当回事。海滩空了，夜幕降临，迎来了12月1日的黎明。有两名骑师正在海滩上练习骑马往返，他们看到这家伙躺在那里，向他挥手，没有任何回应。他们策马沿着海滩跑过去，然后折返回来，他依然一动不动。于是他们从马上下车，
go and look at him and he's dead he's dead so this is a great story this make great film and he is there he is he's leaning there he's got his head against the seawall and there is a great story this make great film and he is there he is he's leaning there he's got his head against the seawall and there is a cigarette that has fallen from his mouth onto the lapel of his jacket very there are various accounts either it's it's it's not been smoked or it's been half smoked right so the various accounts of this and the police come they go through his pockets uh they find a rail ticket from Adelaide, which is unused. They find a bus ticket, which does seem to have been used. They find a comb that's been made in the United States.
过去查看他，发现他已经死了。他死了。所以这是一个极好的故事，拍成电影肯定很棒。他就躺在那里，靠在那里，把头靠在防波堤上，还有一根烟从他嘴里掉落在他夹克的翻领上。各种说法不一，要么是这根烟还没抽过，要么是抽了一半。对，所以对此有各种说法。警察来了，搜查了他的口袋，他们发现了一张来自阿德莱德的火车票，没有用过。他们发现了一张公交车票，似乎用过了。他们发现了一把在美国制造的梳子。
They find a juicy fruit gum, which is also much more available in the United States than in Australia. They find a cigarette pack, army club cigarette pack, which is very cheap cigarettes. And inside, there are more expensive brands of cigarettes. And that's unusual because normally it's the other way around. Normally- Yeah, you wouldn't hide expensive cigarettes in there. So that's odd. But what's even odder is the fact that every single label on the item of clothing that this man is wearing has been surgically removed. There is no wallet. There is absolutely nothing to identify who he is in any way at all. So the police take the body to the local station, to the morgue, and they produce a report on him.
他们发现了一块美味果牌口香糖（juicy fruit gum），这也比在澳大利亚更容易在美国买到。他们发现了一包香烟，是陆军俱乐部（Army Club）牌香烟，这是一种非常便宜的香烟。里面却有更贵牌子的香烟。这很不寻常，因为通常情况正好相反。通常——是的，你不会把贵烟藏在里面。所以这很奇怪。但更奇怪的是，这个男人身上穿的每一件衣服上的每一个标签都被手术般地移除了。没有钱包，绝对没有任何东西可以以任何方式证明他是谁。于是警察把尸体带到当地警局、停尸房，并为他出具了一份报告。
He is a man who is about 40, early 40s, 40, maybe up to 45. Very good looking man, kind of short hair, slight hint of salt and pepper to it very very well built uh no calluses on his hands uh so clearly not a manual laborer um his shoes are beautifully polished which is very very strange if he's been walking up and down a beach yeah they seem to have been just freshly polished so that's very odd and and when they look at his legs his his toes are kind of bunched together and he has the the very pronounced muscles of someone who might have been walking either on high heels or perhaps using uh ballet slippers and so the the person doing the autopsy suggests
这是一个大约40岁、40岁出头、40岁左右、可能高达45岁的男人。长相非常英俊，短发，隐约带有一点盐和胡椒色。身材非常健硕，手上没有老茧，所以显然不是体力劳动者。他的鞋子擦得锃亮，如果他一直在海滩上走来走去，这就非常非常奇怪了。是的，它们看起来像是刚刚擦过，所以这非常奇怪。当他们检查他的脚时，他的脚趾挤在一起，他有着那种可能经常穿高跟鞋或芭蕾舞鞋的人才有的非常明显的肌肉。因此，进行尸检的人推测，
that he may have been a ballet dancer so okay all very intriguing these are very agatha christie style clues very very so then they do they do the autopsy and they find he has a perfectly healthy heart he does have an enlarged spleen uh so that's that is something that's wrong and they find that there is an excess of blood in his liver, in his kidneys, and in his stomach. And this apparently is a strong suggestor of poison. But they can't work out what, if it is poison, and it does seem to be poison because that's what the excess of blood seems to point to. Yeah, because there's no sign of violence.
他可能是一名芭蕾舞演员。好吧，这一切都非常离奇，这些都是非常阿加莎·克里斯蒂风格的线索。非常，非常……然后他们进行了尸检，发现他的心脏非常健康。他确实有脾肿大，所以这是不对劲的地方。他们发现他的肝脏、肾脏和胃里有过多血液。这显然是中毒的强烈迹象。但他们无法查出是什么毒，如果这是中毒的话——而且这似乎确实是中毒，因为血液过多似乎指向这一点。是的，因为没有暴力迹象。
There's no sign of violence at all. But they can't identify what the brand of brand of poison is so if it is a poison it's something quite rare and sophisticated so they're they don't know who this man is did he die of natural causes uh was it suicide was it murder and if it was murder who murdered him the time of death is pinpointed at 2 a.m so in the morning in the morning so kind of midway between you, the people who saw him where he was raising his arm and then when he's found the next morning on the 1st of December. So they don't really know what to do with this. And so they embalm him, they embalm the body to preserve it. And then they start looking around for further clues. And of course, an obvious place to look is in the local station, the cloakroom. They find it in the main station in Adelaide,
完全没有暴力迹象。但他们无法确定毒药的品牌是什么。如果是毒药，那一定是一种相当罕见且复杂的毒药。所以他们不知道这个人是谁，他是死于自然原因？是自杀？还是谋杀？如果是谋杀，是谁谋杀了她？死亡时间被精确定在凌晨2点。所以在清晨。所以在清晨。也就是在那些看到他举起手臂的人离开他，到第二天早上12月1日人们发现他之间的时间中点。所以他们真的不知道该拿这个怎么办。于是他们对他的尸体进行防腐处理，以保存尸体。然后他们开始寻找进一步的线索。当然，一个显而易见的地方就是当地车站的寄存处。他们在阿德莱德的总站找到了，
and they find his suitcase. And what they find there in a way is as frustrating as everything before. They know that it's his because they find a brand of kind of waxed US thread made in the United States, which is the same that he'd been using to darn a rip in his trousers. So it must be his suitcase. There's no correspondence. So again, there's no clue as to who this man is no spare socks interestingly very peculiar again all the labels have been removed from his clothes apart from a tie a laundry bag and a vest and on that on the tie you get t keen so that's k-e-a-n-e you get keen the name on a laundry bag and you get keen k-e-A-N-E. You get Keane, the name on a laundry bag, and you get Keane, K-E-A-N on the vest. And so they think, ah. His name is Keane.
他们找到了他的手提箱。从某种程度上说，在那里发现的东西和之前的一切一样令人沮丧。他们知道那是他的，因为他们发现了一种在美国制造的打蜡美国线，这和他用来缝补裤子裂口的是同一种线。所以那一定他的手提箱。里面没有信件。所以同样地，没有任何关于这个男人是谁的线索。没有备用袜子。有趣的是，又很奇特，他衣服上的所有标签也都被撕掉了，只剩下一个领带、一个洗衣袋和一件背心。在领带上，你可以看到“T·基恩”（T Keane），也就是K-E-A-N-E，你看到了“基恩”，这是洗衣袋上的名字，而你在背心上看到了“基恩”，K-E-A-N。所以他们想，啊。他的名字叫基恩。
He must be, you know, it's just T Keane. So they, obviously they go through all the missing people, register who might be T Keane, not a trace, no sign of anyone T Keane who's gone missing. So they, they try and work out where's this guy come from? He's obviously come from somewhere. So he could have come in. They look at the train train schedules he could have come in from a local town but they think that's unlikely because someone like that would have been seen and they go to all the local towns and nobody remembers seeing anyone corresponding to this guy so the only other train that came in was from melbourne so i think he must have come from melbourne he probably checked his suitcase he bought a ticket to to go to the station then he discovered that there was a bus
他一定……你知道的，这只是T·基恩。所以他们显然查阅了所有失踪人员登记册，看谁可能是T·基恩，毫无踪迹，没有任何叫T·基恩的人失踪的迹象。所以他们试图弄清楚这家伙是从哪儿来的？他显然是从某个地方来的。所以他可能是坐车来的。他们查看了火车时刻表，他可能是从一个当地小镇来的，但他们认为这不太可能，因为像这样的人会被人看到。他们走访了所有当地小镇，没有人记得见过任何符合这个家伙特征的人。所以唯一开进来的另一趟火车是从墨尔本开来的。所以他们认为他一定是从墨尔本来的。他可能寄存了手提箱，买了一张去车站的车票，然后他发现有一辆公交车
going directly to where he wanted, namely to Somerton, that area. So that's why he took the bus. So they think that's probably what happened on the 30th of November. And the decision of the inquest is that it is likely to be poison. So that's kind of the ruling. They don't know what it is, though, what kind of poison. They take a plaster cast of his head and his shoulders and then they bury him in one of
直达他想去的地方，也就是萨顿镇那个地区。所以这就是他坐公交车的原因。因此他们认为这可能就是11月30日发生的事情。死因研讯的裁决是，这很可能是中毒。这就是裁决结果。不过他们不知道是什么毒，是什么样的毒。他们为他的头部和肩膀制作了石膏模型，然后将他埋葬在阿德莱德的一个
the cemeteries in Adelaide and basically it seems like no one's ever going to find out who he is or anything but then then they find a further clue and this is where it gets really really Dorothy Alsae's I mean it's it's so like a kind of 1940s detective story. And do you think we should have a break at this point? I do. I'm absolutely on tenterhooks, Tom. I can't. I'm greatly looking forward to my own screen. Well, it's brilliant.
墓地里。基本上，似乎没有人会知道他是谁或任何事情。但是，接着他们找到了进一步的线索，这就是事情变得真正、真正像多萝西·L·塞耶斯的地方。我的意思是，这太像1940年代的侦探故事了。你觉得我们这时候该休息一下吗？我觉得应该。我完全如坐针毡，汤姆。我不能……我非常期待我自己的屏幕。嗯，这太棒了。
It's an absolutely brilliant. It's such an improbable clue that you'd think this could only have been made up in a detective story. But I will reveal what it is when we come back from the break. It's exciting. So we'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we come back from the break. It's exciting. So we'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这绝对是一部精彩绝伦的作品。这是一个如此不可思议的线索，你会觉得这只能在侦探故事中虚构出来。但我会在我们休息回来后揭晓它是什么。这很令人兴奋。所以我们休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom Holland, you are taking us through the mystery of Somerton Man. So we're in late 1940s Australia in Adelaide.
这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的每周固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。汤姆·霍兰德，你正在为我们讲述萨顿镇神秘男子案。所以我们身处20世纪40年代末澳大利亚的阿德莱德。
And Tom, very tantalisingly before the break, you said you had an amazing clue to reveal. Yes,, very tantalisingly before the break, you said you had an amazing clue to reveal. Yes, a further clue. So what is the clue? So the pathologist is going through the clothes of the Somerton man again, and he discovers right buried down in one of the pockets, the kind of the smallest pocket, he finds a very, very tiny, tiny roll of paper that's been wound up so tightly that he has to use scalpels to extract it from the lining, from the fabric. And he unrolls it. And there he sees printed on it, Tamum Shad. And they go, you know, Tamum Shad? What the hell's that? So they investigate and they discover
汤姆，在休息前非常诱人地，你说你有一个惊人的线索要揭晓。是的，非常诱人地，在休息前你说你有一个惊人的线索要揭晓。是的，又一个线索。那么线索是什么呢？法医再次检查萨顿镇男子的衣服，发现在其中一个口袋的最深处——也就是最小的口袋里——发现了一个非常、非常微小的纸卷，卷得非常紧，以至于他不得不使用手术刀才能将其从衬里、从织物中取出来。他把它展开。然后他在上面看到印着：“塔曼·沙德”（Tamam Shad）。他们心想，你知道，“塔曼·沙德”是什么？那到底是什么鬼东西？所以他们进行了调查，并发现
that it's Persian. So Alianzari would have been straight onto it. And it means it is done, it's finished, it's over, you know, this is the end. And it comes from the Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam, you know, famous Persian poet, polymath from the 11th, 12th century, translated by the Victorian poet Edward Fitzgerald in the middle of the 19th century. And this Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam is that version. That is so bizarre. Just those words, Tamat Shad. And it's been ripped out from an edition of Fitzgerald's poems, the Fitzgerald translation.
那是波斯语。所以阿兰扎里（Alianzari）肯定一眼就能看出。意思是“它完成了”、“结束了”、“完了”，你知道，这就是结局。它出自奥马尔·海亚姆（Omar Khayyam）的《鲁拜集》（Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam），你知道的，这是11、12世纪著名的波斯诗人、多面手，由维多利亚时代的诗人爱德华·菲茨杰拉德（Edward Fitzgerald）在19世纪中叶翻译。奥马尔·海亚姆的《鲁拜集》就是那个版本。这太离奇了。仅仅是这几个字，塔马特·沙德（Tamat Shad）。它是从菲茨杰拉德的诗集版本（菲茨杰拉德译本）中被撕下来的。
And so the police put out an alert saying, does anyone have a copy of this book? Could you look and see whether it's been, the Tamham Shad has been ripped out from it? And they wait. And in due course, amazingly, someone comes forward and says, yes, I've got it. And the story of this man who doesn't want to be, you know, his identity is kept quiet, is that his car was parked by Somerton Park Beach and his windows were open because it was hot. And he came back, you know, having been on the beach and he discovers that this book had been thrown in through the window and he hadn't thought anything more of it. You know, it wasn't anything that particularly attracted his attention. It must have seemed weird to him though. Yeah, it was weird.
于是警方发出警报，询问是否有人有这本书的副本？你们能看看“塔姆汉·沙德”（Tamham Shad）是不是被撕掉了吗？他们等待着。果然，令人惊奇的是，有人站出来说，是的，我有。这个不想暴露身份的男人的故事是，他的车停在萨顿镇公园海滩旁，因为天气很热，车窗开着。他从海滩回来后，发现这本书被从车窗扔了进去，他当时没当回事。你知道，这不是什么特别吸引他注意的东西。不过这对他来说一定很怪异。是的，这很怪异。
Books of Persian poetry through car windows. He did think it was weird, which is why he kept it and why he remembered it was weird it's a persian poetry through yes he did think it was weird which is why he kept it and why he remembered it and it's why when when he reads the announcement the police announcement he turns to the relevant page and discovers that tamer shad is missing from it that this is the very copy yeah and so the police the police inspect it and they find that there are five lines of random letters in the back. And one of these lines has been crossed out and has been put again at the bottom. And they're incomprehensible.
通过车窗扔波斯诗集。他确实觉得这很怪异，这就是为什么他留着它，也是为什么他记得这很怪异。通过车窗扔波斯诗集——是的，他确实觉得这很怪异，这就是为什么他保留了它并记住了它，这也是为什么当他读到警方的通告时，他翻到相关页面，发现“塔默·沙德”（tamer shad）不见了，这就是那一本原版。是的，于是警察检查了它，发现在背面有五行随机字母。其中有一行被划掉了，又写在了底部。它们是不可理解的。
And so is it a code? So they hand it out to all their top boffins, their top code breakers, and nobody can crack it. And so they wonder, is it a kind of shorthand? You know, is it an abbreviation? You know, what is it? Nobody can work out what these letters mean but there's more there are two phone numbers oh this is great stuff one of the phone numbers is the number of a local bank okay but the other phone number is the number of a woman who lives
那么这是密码吗？所以他们把它交给了他们所有的顶级专家、顶尖密码破译人员，没有人能破解它。于是他们想，这是一种速记吗？你知道，这是一个缩写吗？你知道，这是什么？没有人能弄清楚这些字母是什么意思。但还有更多，有两个电话号码。哦，这太棒了。其中一个电话号码是当地一家银行的号码。好吧，但另一个电话号码是一个女人的号码，她住在
about 400 meters from where the body was found oh and the police keep her name, again, they keep her name secret, but in due course, it comes out that she's a woman called Jessica Thompson, who goes by the nickname of Jess. She's a nurse. She has a small boy, a small son, and she's taken down to the station and she looks at the plaster cast and she says she doesn't know him. She has no idea who he is. But according to the policeman who watches her, he says that when she goes to see the body, she was so completely taken aback to the point of giving the appearance she was about to faint. So that's literally what the policeman says. Right. She denies knowing who the Somerton man is.
距离发现尸体的地方大约400米远。哦，警察对她的名字保密，再次保密，但不久之后，人们发现她是一个名叫杰西卡·汤普森（Jessica Thompson）的女人，大家都叫她杰丝（Jess）。她是一名护士。她有一个小男孩，一个小儿子，她被带到警察局，看着石膏模型，她说她不认识他。她不知道他是谁。但根据看着她的警察所说，她说当她去看尸体时，她大吃一惊，甚至露出一副快要昏厥的样子。所以这真的是警察所说的话。对。她否认认识萨顿镇男子。
But she says, yes, the reboot of Omicami is actually my favorite book I love it and I actually gave a copy to uh to this man uh who I met when I was working as a nurse in Sydney uh and he was a lieutenant in the Australian army a man called Alf Boxall and so the police think well obviously the dead man is Alf Boxall case closed brilliant yeah yeah but then he's found alive so it's not alf boxall so strange and so that basically is that is where they end their investigation so what are the theories as to what's been going on and there are various theories. So the first theory is that the Somerton Man was a spy. And this is 1948.
但她说，是的，《奥米卡米》（Omi Cami，即鲁拜集）的重印本其实是我最喜欢的书，我太喜欢它了。我甚至送了一本给……给这个男人，我是在悉尼当护士时认识他的，他当时是澳大利亚陆军的一名中尉，一个叫阿尔夫·博克索尔（Alf Boxall）的男人。所以警察心想，很显然，死者就是阿尔夫·博克索尔，结案，太棒了。对，对。但随后他被发现还活着，所以他不是阿尔夫·博克索尔。太奇怪了。所以基本上，这就是他们结束调查的地方。那么，关于到底发生了什么，有哪些理论呢？有各种各样的理论。因此，第一个理论是萨顿镇男子是一名间谍。这是1948年。
I was about to say Cold War. Classic Cold War. Yeah. The Cold War is kicking in. And there are reasons why particularly Russian spies might be interested in Adelaide. Because about 300 miles northwest of Adelaide, there is a test range called the Woomera Test Range, which at the time is the second busiest rocket range outside Cape Canaveral. And it's headquarters for an Anglo Australian project to develop V2 technology. So you could see why the Russians might be
我正想说冷战。经典的冷战。是的。冷战正在爆发。而且有理由说明，特别是俄国间谍可能会对阿德莱德感兴趣。因为在阿德莱德西北约300英里处，有一个名为“乌默拉靶场”（Woomera Test Range）的测试靶场，在当时，它是除卡纳维拉尔角之外第二繁忙的火箭靶场。它是英澳合作开发V2技术项目标总部。所以你可以理解为什么俄国人可能会
interested in it. Adding to the kind of swirl of paranoia around this is the fact that the mysterious Alf Boxall may well have been involved in intelligence and on top of that uh according to jessica thompson's daughter speaking many years later her mother spoke russian and was very interested in communism oh my word the plot thickens so yeah so you know no hard evidence there but enough to for the conspiracy theorists to get their teeth into yeah because i'm trying to wonder i'm trying to work out what the conspiracy theory here would be i think the conspiracy theory is that she is a spy that she is a spy but who's the dead man because if box or has he has is the man claiming to be box or not box or well various theories
对它感兴趣。为这种偏执狂情绪火上浇油的是这样一个事实：神秘的阿尔夫·博克索尔很可能参与了情报工作。最重要的是，根据杰西卡·汤普森的女儿多年后的说法，她的母亲会说俄语，并且对共产主义非常感兴趣。哦天哪，剧情变得更复杂了！所以，是的，你知道，那里没有确凿的证据，但足以让阴谋论者大快朵颐了。是的，因为我在想，我在琢磨这里的阴谋论会是什么。我认为阴谋论是她是一名间谍，她是一名间谍。但死者是谁呢？如果博克索尔有……声称是博克索尔的人不是博克索尔，好吧，各种理论。
perhaps uh he is an american agent who's been killed by Jessica. Because he was on her case. On her case. Yeah. Perhaps he's a communist agent who Jessica's a double agent. There are any number of permutations. And why the Rubaiyat, maybe they're communicating through the Rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam, sending each other verses. Exactly. And another variation on this is that perhaps he was involved in gun running to Israel, which is being, you know, in the midst of being founded at this point.
也许……他是一个被杰西卡杀害的美国特工。因为他在调查她。在调查她。是的。也许他是一个共产主义特工，而杰西卡是个双重间谍。有无数种排列组合。为什么是《鲁拜集》？也许他们通过奥马尔·海亚姆的《鲁拜集》进行交流，互相发送诗句。正是如此。另一个变体是，也许他参与了向以色列走私武器的活动，当时以色列正处于建国的过程中。
So perhaps he's involved with Palestinians, perhaps he's involved with the Israelis. So the explanations are very much bred of the Cold War paranoia or the kind of post-colonial wars that are breaking out in this period. But there is another theory altogether, which is that it's nothing to do with spies. It's nothing to do with the Cold War, Basically, it's a doomed love affair involving Jessica Thompson, who at the time that the Somerton Man is found, was the mistress of a man called Prosper Thompson, which is where she gets her name from. But she wasn't married to him at that point. He was a married man at that point. And he only leaves his wife and settles down with Jessica in 1950. And at the time, Jessica has this small boy, as I mentioned, who she's called Robin,
所以也许他跟巴勒斯坦人有关，也许他跟以色列人有关。因此，这些解释在很大程度上是由冷战偏执狂或这一时期爆发的某种后殖民战争孕育出来的。但还有另一种完全不同的理论，那就是这与间谍无关。这与冷战无关。基本上，这是一段注定失败的恋爱，涉及杰西卡·汤普森。在发现萨顿镇男子时，她是普罗斯珀·汤普森（Prosper Thompson）的情妇，这也是她名字的由来。但她当时并没有嫁给他。他当时是一个已婚男子。直到1950年，他才离开妻子，与杰西卡安定下来。当时，正如我所提到的，杰西卡带着这个小男孩，他大约出生于1947年。后来他被当作普罗斯珀的儿子抚养长大。多米尼克，当罗宾·汤普森（Robin Thompson）长大后，你觉得他从事什么职业？这是澳大利亚。所以，不，这是最不像澳大利亚人的职业。他不具备澳大利亚人的职业。他是一名消防员。不，他是一名芭蕾舞演员。他成了一名芭蕾舞演员，汤姆，这……成了一名芭蕾舞演员。层层谜团。
who seems to have been born around 1947. And in due course will be brought up as Prosper's son. And Robin Thompson, when he grows up, Dominic, what profession do you think he takes up? It's Australia. So no, it's most un-Australian career. He's un-australian career he's a he's a fire ranger no he's a ballet dancer he becomes a ballet dancer tom this is comes a ballet dancer wheels within wheels yeah and this intrigues a man at the university of adelaide called derrick abbott who is an englishman who's emigrated to Australia, very involved in electrical
是的，这激起了阿德莱德大学一个名叫德里克·阿博特（Derek Abbott）的人的兴趣。他是一个移民到澳大利亚的英国人，非常热衷于电气
engineering. He's a physicist. And he becomes obsessed with the story in the way that lots of people have done. But he is the big Somerton man sleuth. And his theory is that Robin was the son of Jessica Thompson and the Somerton man. And the Somerton man had a kind of strange ear, a kind of distinctive ear pattern. And I can't remember exactly what it is. He had certain teeth were missing. Robin also had these, he had the same ears and teeth, and these are genetic markers. And so the ballet dancing, the teeth, the ears, the circumstantial evidence that he was born you know unknown father so derrick abbott's theory is is that robin was was the summerton man's son and obviously what he really needs is dna to try and prove that hold on if robin was summerton man's son yeah and summerton man has been killed just
工程。他是一位物理学家。和很多人一样，他也对这个故事着迷。但他是一位伟大的萨顿镇男子案侦探。他的理论是，罗宾是杰西卡·汤普森和萨顿镇男子的儿子。萨顿镇男子有一只奇怪的耳朵，一种独特的耳部特征，我不记得具体是什么了。他缺失了某些牙齿。罗宾也有这些特征，他有相同的耳朵和牙齿，而这些是遗传标记。所以芭蕾舞演员的身份、牙齿、耳朵，以及他出生时父亲不详的间谍般的间接证据……所以德里克·阿博特的理论是，罗宾是萨顿镇男子的儿子。显然他真正需要的是DNA来试图证明这一点。等等，如果罗宾是萨顿镇男子的儿子，是的，而萨顿镇男子在杰西卡·汤普森和他儿子居住的地方几百码左右的地方被杀，是的，那么萨顿镇男子可能一直在试图看望他的儿子什么的？也许吧，或者也许他自杀了。是谁杀了他？这又是一个问题。开放式问题。但也许他自杀了。我的意思是，也许，你知道，也许他去见他的儿子，杰西卡不让他进去，他走开，躺下，吃点毒药什么的，也许因为他是个间谍。这就是为什么杰西卡看到他时会有那种反应。但奥马尔·海亚姆的《鲁拜集》和奇怪的信息又作何解释呢？确实如此。确实如此。
a few hundred yards or whatever from where jessica thompson was living with his son yeah then summerton man might have been trying to visit his son or something perhaps or perhaps he committed suicide who was who murdered him that's the question again open question but perhaps he committed suicide i mean perhaps you know maybe he had a he went to see his son jessica wouldn't let him in he goes off lies down takes some poison or something perhaps because he's a spy. And this is why Jessica reacts in that way when she sees him. But then what about the rubaiyat of Omar Khayyam and the strange message? Indeed. Indeed.
所以德里克·阿博特意识到，解决这个谜题的唯一方法基本上就是获得DNA。是的。他真正需要的是来自萨顿镇男子的DNA，以及来自罗宾或罗宾的一个孩子的DNA。而罗宾到这个时候已经去世了。但他留下了一个叫雷切尔（Rachel）的女儿。是的。德里克·阿博特联系上了雷切尔。
So Derek Abbott realises that basically the only way to solve this riddle is to get DNA. Yeah. What he really needs, he needs DNA from the Somerton man, and he needs DNA from either Robin or one of Robin's children. And Robin, by this point, has died. But he has left behind a daughter called Rachel. Yeah. And Derek Abbott gets in touch with Rachel.
在见到她的一天之内，他们就订婚了。一天？一天。天哪，他们可真不含糊。所以，德里克·阿博特和雷切尔——罗宾的女儿、杰西卡的孙女——结婚了。等等，我正试图理清头绪：这位专家兼阴谋论者兼业余侦探、这位教授——他是教授还是别的什么？不管他是什么——现在娶了萨顿镇男子的潜在孙女。
And within a day of meeting her, they're engaged to be married. A day? A day. Golly, they didn't mess about so uh derrick abbott and rachel robin's daughter jessica's granddaughter get married hold on i'm just trying to get my head around this so the expert stroke conspiracy theorist stroke amateur sleuth the professor was he a professor or whatever whatever he is he has now married the possible granddaughter of the Somerton man.
也就是他一直在调查其死因的那个人的孙女。是的。好吧，阿加莎·克里斯蒂大概不会把这个写进去，我想。正是如此。他们有了三个孩子，婚姻非常美满。那很好。彼此深爱对方。雷切尔开玩笑说，他娶她只是为了她的DNA。
Of the man whose death he's investigating. Yes. Well, Agatha Christie probably wouldn't put that in, I don't think. Exactly. And they have three children and they're very happily married. That's nice. Love each other very much. And Rachel has joked that he only married her for her DNA.
好吧，这当然……难道这不是任何人结婚的最终目的吗，汤姆？是的，我想是的，我想是的。但是，显然他非常渴望挖出萨顿镇男子的尸体并提取DNA。这不是很诡异吗，跟一个整天说“我等不及要挖出你爷爷”的人结婚？所以，当地的法律当局说不行，你不能这么做。于是他做的是去查看萨顿镇男子的死亡面具。并在那里找到了留在石膏中的各种毛发。他提取了毛发，发现它们质量足够好，可以提取DNA。
Well, surely that's... Isn't that why anybody gets married tom ultimately yeah i suppose i suppose but uh but obviously he so he's desperate to to dig up the corpse of the summerton man and extract dna that's a weird thing isn't it to be married to somebody just say i can't wait to dig up your grandfather so um the uh the the local legal authorities say no you can't do it so what he does is he goes and looks at the death mask of the Somerton man. And there he finds various hairs that have been left in the plaster. And he extracts the hairs and he discovers that they're good enough to get the DNA.
我不知道，科学家们做什么，你肯定知道，多米尼克，他们研究DNA。我热爱科学。是的。DNA起作用了吗？是的，他做了DNA研究。他与一位名叫科琳·菲茨帕特里克（Colleen Fitzpatrick）的美国家谱学家合作。你知道，他们是基于这样的假设开展工作的：罗宾是萨顿镇男子的儿子，因此萨顿镇男子与杰西卡·汤普森有染，这就是整个谜团的关键。今年7月26日，他们宣布了DNA测试的结果。就在今年夏天，就在今年夏天。你认为罗宾是萨顿镇男子的儿子吗？我想说是，但我决定说不，因为不，他不是。他不是，他不是。所以他们现在已经确认了，他们设法确认了他是谁。他们知道萨顿镇男子是谁了。他们百分之百确定。
And I don't know, whatever scientists do, you'd know, Dominic, they work on the DNA. I love science. Yeah. Does DNA work? Yeah, he does DNA work. And he teams up with this american genealogist called colleen fitzpatrick and you know they're operating on the assumption that that that robin was the son of summerton man and therefore the summerton man had an affair with
虽然澳大利亚警方还没有官方接受这一点，但我听了这位美国专家的解释，用了很多非常与DNA相关的术语。我没听懂，但听起来非常、非常权威。所以他是一个叫卡尔·韦伯（Carl Webb）的人，查尔斯·韦伯（Charles Webb）是他的名字。他是墨尔本一个澳籍德国夫妇的第六个孩子。他有一个小舅子，小舅子的名字叫托马斯·基恩（Thomas Keen）。不过你通常不会穿着你小舅子的衣服带着手提箱到处跑，对吧？不，你不会。所以我的意思是，也许他衣服短缺，我不知道。但我的意思是，你知道，确实有这种联系。
with jessica thompson and this is the key to the whole riddle and this summer 26th of july they announced the results of the dna tests it was just this summer just this summer and do you think that robin was summerton man's son i want to say yes but i'm going to say no because no he wasn't he wasn't he wasn't so they have now identified they've managed to identify uh who it was they know who summerton identified, they've managed to identify who it was. They know who Somerton Man was. They know who Somerton Man was. They're kind of 100% certain.
确实有明确的联系。好吧。他曾与托马斯·基恩的姐姐结过婚，并在1947年4月离开了妻子。那是关于他的最后记录。在那之后没有关于他的其他记录。所以他死了——如果真的是这家伙，如果这就是卡尔·韦伯的话，他死于12月1日。所以，你知道，在他失踪期间，已经过去相当长一段时间了。
It hasn't been officially accepted by the Australian police, but they, I've listened to the American specialist explain it in very DNA related terms. I didn't understand it, but it sounded very, very authoritative. So it is a man called Carl Webb webb charles webb he was known as and he was the sixth child of an australian german couple born in melbourne and he had a brother-in-law and the brother-in-law's name thomas keen but you don't normally walk around with a suitcase your brother in law's clothes do you no you don't so i mean there are i mean maybe he was short of clothes i don't know but i mean you know there is, there is that, that is linking, you know, there is a link.
1951年，他的妻子开始对他提起离婚诉讼，理由是他遗弃了她。我们所了解的关于卡尔·韦伯的其他细节……我们没有他的照片，但我们知道他喜欢诗歌，因此也就有了《鲁拜集》……是的。我们知道他喜欢赛马，所以德里克·阿博特的理论是，神秘的密码实际上是马匹的名字，也许是参赛马匹的名字，这样他就可以押注它们或类似的东西。他为什么要剪掉衣服上的所有名字？不知道。所以还有很多谜团悬而未决。他为什么会有便宜的烟和昂贵的……不知道。
There is a definitive link. Okay. And he'd been married to Thomas Kean's sister and he'd left his wife in April 1947. And that was the last record of him. There is no other record of him after that. So he dies, you know, if it is this guy, if it is Carl Webb, he died in, in, on the 1st of December. So, you know, that's quite a while where he's gone missing.
哦，反过来。是的，我们不知道。他为什么会有芭蕾舞演员的腿？他看起来并不像个芭蕾舞演员。芭蕾舞演员的腿。这就像某种希腊神话中的生物，对吧？男人的身体和芭蕾舞演员的腿。他喜欢穿细高跟鞋吗？我的意思是，你知道，我们不知道。是的，这与杰西卡·汤普森完全没有联系。据他们所知没有？没有。那完全是个红鲱鱼（误导线索）。没有。好吧，那他为什么要给她打电话？因为她的名字在书里。
And in 1951, his wife began divorce proceeding against him on the grounds that he deserted her and other other details that we know about carl webb we don't have a photograph of him but we know that he enjoyed poetry so hence the revite yeah yeah maybe and we know that he enjoyed betting on horses and so uh derrick abbott's theory is that that the mysterious code is in fact the names of horses, maybe runners, so he could bet on them or something like that. Why had he cut out all the names in his clothes? Don't know. So there are lots of mysteries that remain. Why did he have cheap cigarettes and expensive... Don't know.
所以他可能在罗宾的父亲和普罗斯珀（不管他叫什么名字）背后与她有过一段关系吗？那博克索尔先生呢？他也只是个红鲱鱼。我觉得他看起来确实有点像个红鲱鱼，但同样，我们无法确定。我们不知道，如果这就是卡尔·韦伯，我们不知道他与杰西卡·汤普森有什么联系。我们不知道他为什么来到萨顿镇海滩。我们不知道是什么导致了他的死。我们不知道他与杰西卡·汤普森有什么联系。我们不知道他为什么来到萨顿镇海滩。我们不知道是什么导致了他的死。我们不知道他是自杀的、是自然死亡、还是被谋杀，如果是被谋杀，又是谁干的。
Oh, the other way around. Yeah, we don't know that. Why did he have the legs of a ballet dancer? He doesn't seem to be a ballet dancer. The legs of a ballet dancer. It's like a sort of Greek myth creature, isn't it? The body of a man and the legs of a ballet dancer. Did he like wearing stilettos? I mean, you know, we don't know. Yeah, there's no connection with Jessica Thompson at all. Not that they know? No. That was an absolute red herring. No. Well, why did he phone her? Because her name was in the book.
我的意思是，这一切仍然是个未知数。这太诱人了。所以对于各种调查来说，仍然有巨大的空间。但我认为，其中有趣的一点，也许对阴谋论和耸人听闻的谋杀理论的历史编纂学有更普遍的启示意义——所以我看着你，开膛手杰克（Jack the Ripper）——那就是人们被最宏大的理论所吸引，比如他是间谍，他是美国特工，也许他是来自欧洲的难民，他参与了间谍活动。我的意思是，这些理论是最有市场的。我记得这些是我在阿德莱德第一次听到关于他的演讲时听到的理论。它们是最戏剧性的理论。
So had he perhaps had a relationship with her behind the back of Robin's father and Prosper, whatever his name is? And what about Mr. Boxall? He was a red herring as well. I think he does look a bit of a red herring, but again, we can't be sure. We don't know what, you know, what this, if it is Carl Webb, we don't know what his connection is to Jessica Thompson. We don't know why he came to Somerton Beach. We don't know what caused his death. We don't know what his connection is to Jessica Thompson. We don't know why he came to Somerton Beach. We don't know what caused his death. We don't know whether he killed himself, whether it was natural causes, whether he was murdered, and if he was murdered by whom.
是的，当然。但实际上，你知道，他只是来自墨尔本的澳大利亚普通人。当他死时，似乎没有人注意到他死了。我的意思是，他就像人间蒸发了一样。但这非常符合黄金时代侦探小说的风格，因为在阿加莎·克里斯蒂的书里，她会创造这些极其精致的场景，有钟表，有诸如《ABC谋杀案》之类的事情，然而结局总是非常平庸、非常乏味，关乎金钱，或者关乎对爱情的失望什么的。所有这一切都只是烟幕弹，现实是非常世俗的。
I mean, all of this remains unknown. And it's so tantalising. And so there's still a huge scope for kind of investigation. But I think that one of the things that's interesting about it and perhaps suggestive more generally for the historiography of conspiracy theories and sensational murder theories. So I'm thinking of looking at you, Jack the Ripper, is that people were attracted towards the most grandiose theories, that he was a spy, that he was an American agent, perhaps that he was a refugee from Europe, that he was involved in espionage. I mean, the theories were that had the most currency. And I remember these were the theories that I
这就是魔术师的把戏，对吧？是的。你也是说，这也适用于这个案件，最终——当然，有趣的是，阴谋论是1940年代政治气候的产物，完全如此。所以它们都围绕着冷战焦虑之类的事情。哦，汤姆，这是……这是我听过的关于澳大利亚最棒的一件事。这是一个很棒的故事，不是吗？
heard when I first heard this talk in Adelaide about him. They were the most dramatic theories. Yeah, of course. But actually, you know, he'sralian bloke from melbourne and and when he died nobody seems to have noticed that he died i mean he just vanished but that's very golden age of detective fiction because in agatha christie's book she would create these incredibly elaborate scenarios with clocks and with sort of the abc murders and stuff and yet the solution is always very banal and very humdrum and it's about money or it's about sort of disappointment in love or something and all of that was a smokescreen the reality is very kind of mundane
这真的是一个很棒的故事。实际上，我觉得我们应该……我觉得我们应该去澳大利亚，我想去这个海滩。我觉得我们不仅应该做……你知道的，那种“人在囧途”式的重走萨顿镇男子之路，我觉得我们……
that's the magician's trick isn't it yeah and you're saying that with this as well that ultimately and of course the interesting thing is that the conspiracy theory is a bread of the political climate of the 1940s completely so they're all about the old war anxieties and things yeah oh tom this is joe this is this is the single best thing I've ever heard about Australia. It's, it's, it's a great story, isn't it?
这就是魔术师的把戏，对吧？是的，你也认为这个也是如此，归根结底，有趣的是，阴谋论正是1940年代政治气候的产物，完全就是这样。所以它们都关乎二战的焦虑之类的事情，对吧？哦，汤姆，这是乔，这是我听过的关于澳大利亚最棒的事情。这是一个非常棒的故事，对吧？
It's a really great story. Actually, I think we should, I think we should go to Australia and I'd like to go to this beach. And I think not only should we do, you know, a sort of the trip style in the footsteps of summits and man, I think we
这确实是一个非常棒的故事。实际上，我觉得我们应该去澳大利亚，我想去这个海滩。而且我认为我们不仅应该进行那种沿着萨米特和曼恩足迹的旅行，我还觉得我们
should try and crack the case sandbrook and holland investigate ah that's a series isn't it cops on the edge cops on the edge i'm afraid you'd very much be the inspector lestrade figure and i would be that i would be the tall angular sherlock holmes you'd be the pipe smoking sidekick i hate to tell you this i am am Kevin Waitley and you are Lawrence Fox. Nonsense. I'm John Thor. You're Kevin Waitley. Well, anyway, so there it is. And so, I mean, I think actually, interestingly, this is almost the first episode we've done where we don't, you know, it's history that as yet is massively waiting to be written. So we've, you know, this extraordinary history that as yet is massively waiting to be written.
应该去侦破桑德布鲁克和霍兰德调查这个案子，啊，那是一部剧集吧？边缘警察，边缘警察，恐怕你很大程度上会是雷斯特拉德探长那样的角色，而我会是……我会是那个高大瘦削的夏洛克·福尔摩斯，你就是那个抽烟斗的搭档，我不得不告诉你，我是凯文·韦特利，你是劳伦斯·福克斯。胡说八道。我是约翰·索尔。你是凯文·韦特利。好吧，不管怎样，事情就是这样。所以，我的意思是，实际上有趣的是，这几乎是我们做过的第一期节目，我们没有……你知道，这段历史至今还有待大书特书。所以我们，你知道，这段非凡的历史至今还有待大书特书。
So we've, you know, this extraordinary development that we've got to this summer, but still so many questions to be answered. Well, that is a brilliant, a brilliant topic, Tom. And I don't think if we, if in the rest of this World Cup series, we have a story to top that or even to equal it, I will be absolutely amazed. So as you would say, that was an absolute tour de force. Thanks, mate. All right. Good on you. Well, we shall see you, I suppose, tomorrow for more World Cup-themed podcasts.
所以我们，你知道，经历了今年夏天这个非凡的发展，但仍有许多问题亟待解答。好吧，汤姆，这是一个绝妙的、绝妙的话题。我不认为在我们接下来的这届世界杯系列节目中，会有什么故事能超越它，甚至与之平分秋色，我会感到非常震惊。所以正如你所说，那真是一次精彩绝伦的杰作。谢谢，老兄。好的。干得好。好吧，我想我们明天会再见面，带来更多以世界杯为主题的播客。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest is history pod.com i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，想要获取额外单集、提前收听、无广告体验以及访问我们的聊天社区，请登录 rest is history pod.com 注册，网址是 rest is history pod.com，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》，restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。